I know this has seemed pretty easy so far, but there's something else that's
really interesting about 1/4. I can represent 1/4 in other ways. Like if I had a
clock. So, if I start on the hour, I could go 15 minutes. I could go another 15
minutes, I could go another 15 minutes, and I could go another 15. I know an
hour is 60 minutes so I just need to go 1/4 of that way. So, 1/4 is going to be
one 15-minute period. This is 1/4 of my one hour. 1/4 could also represent part
of an area of a square. Here's a square, notice that I split the square up into
4 parts. If I shade one of those parts, I have 1 out of 4 or 1/4. Notice that in
both cases, I split up my whole part into 4 equal pieces. I split the square up
into 4 equal pieces and I split my hour up into 4 15-minute time intervals.
What's really important is that we always create equally sized pieces. What's
also interesting is that I could have actually split up my square a bit
differently, I could have drawn this. So, if I shaded in this area, I know that
I'd have 1/4 or 1 out of 4 equally divided pieces.